bonjour claudio qu'elle fût qui remercie
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors avant de parler un des dernières
heures au pouvoir de raul castro
j'aimerais revenir avec vous sur cette
invasion raté un de la baie des cochons
en 1961 qu'est ce que cet épisode
représente aujourd'hui dans l'histoire
cubaine
oui au delà de bonjour à tous au-delà de
l'histoire cubaine je pense que cet
épisode représente un moment historique
et un moment morale pour cuba mais
surtout pour pour les peuples dans le
monde et pour la politique dans le monde
la première des choses c'est justement
cette question de l'ingérence étrangère
qui est deux qui est au coeur de la
question et de l'histoire un peu des
états unis et tout particulièrement en
amérique latine donc et cette question
morale qui est un peu dégagé comment un
état qui se situe loin des autres des
autres pays en tout cas loin
politiquement loin des peuples des
volonté des peuples souhaite en tout cas
par la force changé les changer les
choses et là la réponse du peuple cubain
a été à ce moment-là claire et un
message clair envoyé à tous les états
unis donc c'est savons tous ce message
et de réponse de souveraineté populaire
face à des tentatives d'ingérences de
l'oncle sam
entre entre guillemets bien évidemment
mais de att états unis et on constate
que soixante ans après à cette situation
et elle guère évolué on va dire cc
volonté d'ingérence ou c c'est peut-être
à traverser ces moments historiques ce
c'est ces questions qui sont qui sont
posés à l'ensemble des peuples dans le
monde
même si en france c'est qu'elle est
lâche quelle est la part de la
souveraineté populaire dans la politique
mondiale
la clé au lieu qu'elle fût pires que
c'est également cet épisode qui a
popularisé à fidel castro et qui en fait
l'homme politique que l'on que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
ce moment on a vraiment fait partie mais
je pense qu'il y en a il y en a bien
d'autres puisqu'il faut reprendre un peu
le contexte je pense de de ce moment on
est juste après avec quelques années
après la révolution cubaine donc le
premier moment de le populariser ses
dettes et ses 7,7 révolution cubaine qui
a été suivie en quasi simultané par les
quatre coins du monde
c'est à ces barbus comme comme il si
tommy simple et avec ce qu'ils ont
ces barbus politique à qui on dit qu'ils
vont gagner la souveraineté populaire
d'hésiter nouvelle d'inspiration
marxiste et qui arrive à ce moment là en
deux à prendre le pouvoir avec le peuple
et donc c'est je pense que ça en fait
partie effectivement toute la difficulté
justement deux de l'ingérence des
etats-unis ont fait partie aussi malgré
donc cette volonté de montrer la force
et que même ça ils ont pas réussi à le
faire à ceux à ce moment là montrent
toutes là toute la morale de l'histoire
est une certaine forme d'une certaine
façon la lutte des classes
david contre goliath les ouvriers contre
contre les patrons c'est tous ces
symboles là qui sont dégagées par par
cette baie des cochons à ce moment là
claudio qu'elle fût qui on en parle est
également tout à l'heure raul castro va
prendre sa retraite dans aller
les jours à venir le petit frère de
fidel castro ne sera plus au pouvoir
qu'est ce que ça représente ça justement
dans l'histoire politique cubaine est ce
qu'on tourne définitivement une page
alors une page je ne sais pas c'est si
les cubains qui sont en train de le dire
mais une chose est sûre si tu veux si tu
veux il y avait déjà eu des changements
il ya quelques quelques années de ça il
y avait déjà eu semble-t-il raul castro
était a été s'était déjà retiré de la de
la présidence la haye ce qui semble être
city se retire du du parti il laisse la
place un peu trop jeune les cubains en
train de délire une nouvelle une
nouvelle ère une nouvelle période et je
pense que tout ceci se fait avec une
transition dirais plutôt plutôt
populaire dans le sens dans le centre
urbain et donc c'est assez paradoxal
mais effectivement ou me poser la
question et il ya dix ans lorsque
c'était les 50 ans de la de cette
mémoire delà de la baie des cochons y
aller où il y avait également un congrès
du parti communiste cubain à ce moment
là et donc c'est je pense que c'est
assez paradoxal ce sont des dates
symboliques ce sont des nouvelles
guerres qui se dit ce qu'ils sont en
train de se donner mais pour autant la
philosophie de cuba reste à mon sens
puisque j'en vois toujours la même merci
beaucoup claudio qu'elle fût fier
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
frange rappelle avec nous est secrétaire
national du parti de gauche et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine merci
beaucoup